in this video you learn about some of
the classic neural network architecture
statue of Lynette 5 and then Alex adds
and then GGG net let's take a look
here's team Lynette 5 architecture you
sawed-off of an image which say 32 by 32
by one and the Goblin at five was to
recognize handwritten digits Olivia
image of a digit like that and Lynette
five was trained on grayscale images
which is why it's 32 by 32 by one this
neural network architecture is actually
quite similar to the last example you
saw last week in the first step you use
a set of six five by five filters with a
stride of one because you use six
filters you end up with a twenty by
twenty eight by six over there and with
a stride of one and no padding the image
dimensions reduces from 32 by 32 down to
28 by 28 then the Lynette neural network
applies pooling and Bank then when this
paper was written people used average
pooling much more if you're building a
modern variant you probably use max
pooling instead but in this example your
average pool and with a filter width of
2 in Australia - you wind up reducing
the dimensions the height and width by a
factor of two so you now end up with a
14 by 14 by 6 volume I guess the height
and width of these volumes on entirely
drones a scale you know technically if I
were drawing his volumes to scale the
height and width would be stronger by a
factor of 2 next you apply another
convolutional layer this time you use a
set of 16 filters that 5x5 so you end up
with 16 channels to the next volume and
back when this paper was written in 1998
people didn't really use having or
you're always using valid convolutions
which is why every time you apply a
convolutional layer the height and width
strengths so that's why
here you go from 14 to 14 down to 10 by
10 then another pulling layer so that
reduces a height of
by factor of two and you end up with
five by five over here and if we
multiply out these numbers 5/16 this
multiplies out to four hundred and
that's 25 times 16 is 400 and the next
layer is then a fully connected layer
that fully connects each of these 400
notes with every one of a hundred and
twenty neurons so there's a fully coming
to layer and sometimes that would draw
out you know explicitly a layer 400
noodles from skipping that here there's
a fully connected layer and then another
fully connected layer and then the final
step is it uses these you know
essentially 84 features and uses it with
one final output I guess you could draw
one more node here to make a prediction
for Y hat and Y hat took on 10 possible
values corresponding to recognizing each
of the digits from 0 to 9 a modern
version of this new network would use a
soft max layer with a 10-way
classification output although back then
Lynnette 5 actually used a different
classifier at the output layer one data
useless today so this new network was
small by modern standards had about
60,000 parameters and today you often
see neural networks with anywhere from
10 million to a hundred million
parameters and is not unusual to see
networks there are literally about a
thousand times bigger than this network
but one thing you do see is that as you
go deeper and then that networks as you
go from left to right the height and
width tend to go down so you went from
32 by 32 to 28 to 14 to 10 to 5 where as
the number of channels tends to increase
it goes from 1 to 6 to 16 as you go
deeper into the layers of the network
one other pattern you see in this new
network there's still often repeated
today is that you may have some come one
or more complex followed by pooling
layer and then
one or sometimes more than one can flare
followed by a pooling layer and then
some fully connected layers and then the
output right so this type of arrangement
of layers is quite common now finally
this is maybe only for those of you that
want to try reading the paper there are
a couple of other things that were
different the rest of this slide I'm
going to make a few more advanced
comments only for those of you that when
they try to meet this classic paper and
so everything I'm gonna write and read
you can safely skip on the slide and
this may be an interesting historical
footnote that is okay if you don't
follow fully so it turns out that if you
read the original paper back then people
use sigmoid and tannic nonlinearities
and people weren't using really
nonlinearities back then so if you local
paper you see sigmoid and chanak
referred to and there are also some
funny ways about this network was Maya
at least funny by modern standards so
for example you've seen how if you have
a image by NW by NC network with NC
channels then you use F by F by the same
NC dimensional filter where every filter
looks at every one of these channels but
back then computers were much slower and
so to save on computation as well as on
parameters the original n85 has some
crazy complicated where where different
filters look at different channels of
the input block and so the paper talks
about those details but a more modern
implementation you know wouldn't have
that type of complexity these days and
then one last thing that was done back
then I guess but isn't really done right
now is that you're almost on the net
five had a non-linearity after pooling
right and I think that you use a sigmoid
non-linearity after the pooling layer so
if you do read this paper and this is
one of the harder ones to beat of the
ones we'll go over in the next
the next one might be an easier one to
start with most of the ideas on this
slide are described in sections 2 & 3 of
the paper and later sections in the
paper talk about some other ideas it
talked about something called the draft
transform and network which isn't widely
used today so if you do try to meet this
paper I recommend focusing on really on
section 2 which talks about this
architecture and maybe take a quick look
at section 3 which has a bunch of
experimental results which are pretty
interesting the second example of a
neural network I want to show you is
Alex net named after Alex rejewski who
was the first author of the paper
describing this work the other authors
were Elias us cover and Geoffrey Hinton
so Alex net inputs starts with 2 to 7 by
2 - 7 by 3 images oh and if you read the
paper the paper refers to 2 to 4 by 2 to
4 by 3 images but if you look at numbers
I think that the numbers make sense only
Urvashi to 27 by 227 and then the first
layer applies a sense of 96 11 by 11
filters where they strive for and
because it uses a large either for the
dimensions shrinks to 55 by 55 so
roughly going down by a factor of four
because of the last ride and then
applies max pulling with a three by
three filter so F equals three and a
stride of two so this reduces the volume
to 27 by 27 by 96 and then it performs a
5 by 5 same convolution so we're adding
C and F were in from 27 by 27 by 276 max
pooling again this then reduces the
height and width to 13 and then another
same convolution so same padding so it's
13 by 13 by now 384 filters and then 3
by 3 same convolution again gives you
that then 3 by 3 same convolution gives
you that max pool brings it down to 6 by
6 by 256
if you multiply out these numbers six
times six times 256 that's 9216 so we're
gonna unroll this into nine thousand
thirteen sixteen notes and then finally
it has a view fully connected layers and
then finally uses the softmax to output
which one of 1,000 courses the object
could be so this new network actually
had a lot of similarities to the net but
it was much bigger
so whereas Linette Linette five from the
previous slide had sixty thousand about
sixty thousand parameters this Alec's
net had about sixty million parameters
and the fact that they could take meal
pretty similar basic building blocks but
have a lot more hidden units in training
on a lot more data was he trained on the
image net data set that allowed it to
have this remarkable performance another
aspect of this architecture they made it
much better than the net was using the
revenue activation function and then
again just if you read the baby paper
some more advanced details that you
don't really need to worry about if you
don't read the paper one is that when
those people was written GPUs were still
a little bit slower so it had a
complicated way of training on two GPUs
and the basic idea was that a lot of
these layers was actually split across
two different GPUs and there was a
thoughtful way for when the two GPUs
would communicate with each other and
the paper also the original Alex net
architecture also had a node type of
layer called a local response
normalization and this type of layer
isn't really used much which is why I
didn't talk about it but the basic idea
of local response normalization is if
you look at one of these blocks one of
these volumes that we have on top let's
say for the sake of argument this one
you know 13 by 13 by 256 what local
response normalization ORN does is you
look at one position
so one position heightened with and look
down this across all the channels look
at all 256 numbers and normalize them
and the motivation for this local
response normalization was that for each
position in this 13 by 13 image maybe
you don't want too many neurons with a
very high activation but subsequently
many researchers have found that this
doesn't help that much so this is one of
those ideas that guess I'm drawing in
red because it's less important for you
to understand this one and in practice I
don't really use vocal response
normalizations you know really in the
networks that I were trained today so if
you're interested in the history of deep
learning I think even before Alex that
deep learning was starting to gain
traction in speech recognition in a few
other areas but it was really this paper
that convinced a lot of the computer
vision community to take a serious look
at deep learning to convince them that
deep learning really works in computer
vision and then they grew on to have a
huge impact not just in computer vision
but beyond computer vision as well and
if you want to try reading some of these
papers yourself and you really don't
have to for this course but if you want
to try reading some of these papers this
one is one of the easier ones to read so
this might be a good one to take a look
at so where as Alex Ned had a relatively
complicated architecture there's just a
lot of hyper parameters right where you
have all these numbers that Alex
Rusedski and his co-authors had to come
up with let me show you a third and
final example in this video called the
VGA or the bgg 16 network and a
remarkable thing about the vgg 16 is
that they said instead of having so many
hyper parameters list use a much simpler
network where you focus on just having
conflicts that are just three by three
filters with us try the one and always
use same padding and make all your max
pooling layers two by two over stride of
two and so one very nice thing about the
G network was really simplified these
neural network architectures so let's go
through the architecture so you start up
with an image and then the first two
layers are convolutions which are
therefore these three by three filters
and in the first layers first two layers
you use 64 filters so you end up with a
two to four by two to four because using
same convolutions and then with 64
channels so because VG 16 is a
relatively deep network I'm going to not
draw all the volumes here so what does
little picture de knows is what we would
previously have drawn as this 2 to 4 by
2 to 4 by 3 and then a convolution that
results in I guess a 2 to 4 by 2 to 4 by
64 some picture on this a deeper volume
and then another layer that results in
you know 2 to 4 by 2 to 4 by 64 so this
con 64 times 2 represents that you're
doing 2 layers to conflate with 64
filters and as I mentioned earlier the
filters are always 3 by 3 with Australia
1 and they're always same compositions
so rather than drawing all these volumes
I'm just not use text to represent this
network mix then uses a pulling layer so
the pooling layer will reduce anything
about it goes from 2 to 4 by 2 to 4 down
to what rate goes to 1 12 and 112 by 64
and then it has a couple more conflicts
so this means that it has a 128 filters
and because he's the same convolutions
let's see what's the new dimension all
right it'll be 1 2 up by 112 by 128 and
then pulling layer so you can figure out
what's the new dimension right it'll be
damned and now three comp layers with
256 dimensional filters you have to 256
filters sorry - the pooling layer and
then a few more conflicts pulling layer
more conflicts
pooling layer
and then it takes this final seven by
seven by five to twelve fees it's a
fully connected layer fully connected
with four engine 4096 units and in a
soft next output one of a thousand
classes the by the way does sixteen in
the name vgg sixteen refers to the fact
that this has 16 layers that have some
weights and this is a pretty large
network this network has a total of
about hundred and thirty-eight million
parameters and that's pretty long even
by modern standards but the simplicity
of the vgg 16 architecture made it quite
appealing you can tell this architecture
is really quite uniform there's a few
conflicts followed by a pooling layer
which reduces the height and width right
so the pooling layers reduce the height
and width you have a few of them here
but and also if you look at the number
of filters in the conflicts here you
have 64 filters and then you double to
one to eight double to 256 double to 512
and then I guess the authors thought 5-2
was big enough and didn't jump over the
game here but this you know so they're
roughly doubling on every step or
doubling through every stack of
conflicts was another simple principle
used to design the architecture of this
network and so I think the relative
uniformity of this architecture made it
quite attractive to researchers the main
downside was that it was a pretty large
network in terms in the number of
parameters you had to Train oh and if
you read the literature you sometimes
see people talk about the GG 19 there's
an even bigger version of this network
and you can see the details in the paper
and cited at the bottom by karen simeon
and andrew zisserman but because VG 16
does almost as well as the GG 19 a lot
of people will use eg 16 but the thing I
liked most about this was that this made
this
patent of how as you go deeper
heightened Grif goes down it just goes
down by a factor of two each time for
the pooling layers whereas the number of
channels increases and here it you know
roughly goes up by a factor of two every
time you have a new set of confluence so
by making the rate at which these goes
down and that go up very easy semantics
I thought this paper was very very
attractive from that perspective so
that's it for the three classic
architectures if you want you should
even now meet some of these papers I
recommend starting with the Alex net
paper followed by the vgg net paper and
then the Linette paper is a bit harder
to read but it is a good classic let's
take a look at that but Nick's let's go
beyond these classic networks and look
at some even more advanced even more
powerful neural network architectures
let's go onto the next video